mais protège ou de la mode la gêne
causée par contre quand même ma cousine
symboliquement gaiman
le delta du fleuve rouge terres fertiles
grenier à riz du nord-vietnam le long du
fleuve s'égrènent les villages où depuis
toujours les paysans cultivent le riz
dans une quinzaine d'entre eux se
perpétue encore une tradition millénaire
c'est le spectacle des marionnettes sur
l'eau une fois par an à la fin de la
récolte de printemps les paysans
artistes font une pause dans leurs
travaux agricoles pour redevenir
montreur de marionnettes et préparer un
spectacle qu'ils offrent à leurs
villages le village de dông nous est
l'un des rares à disposer encore d'une
corporation d'une trentaine de
marionnettistes qui se transmettent de
père en fils leur art et leur secret
d'autres corporations n'ont pas eu cette
chance
les conditions économiques difficiles
des campagnes oblige de plus en plus les
paysans à trouver un gagne-pain entre
les deux saisons du riz alors ils
partent travailler comme journalier à la
ville abandonnant leurs marionnettes et
leur spectacle
ainsi une à une les corporations de
marionnettistes disparaissent de la
campagne où elles sont nées
c'est un moteur
chaque corporation est rattachée à son
propre village
l'admission d'un nouveau membre ne se
fait pas à la légère
elle est réservée à quelques familles
seulement et doit être acquise à
l'unanimité tout nouveau membre doit
prêter serment de garder les secrets de
la corporation et de payer ses
cotisations être membres d'une
corporation est un honneur mais une
charge aussi quand il faut en plus des
travaux des champs faire des répétitions
ou construire de nouvelles marionnettes
les marionnettistes ne retire
pratiquement aucun avantage matériel de
leur présence au sein de la corporation
puisque les représentations ne sont pas
payantes mais les liens de solidarité
entre membres sont très forts et en cas
de malheur chacun peut compter sur le
soutien de toute la communauté
l'origine précise des marionnettes sur
l'eau est incertaine mais on en trouve
des évocations écrite dès le 11e siècle
depuis presque mille ans donc les
numéros de marionnettes les techniques
de fabrication et de manipulation ont
été jalousement gardés au sein d'une
trentaine de corporation de paysans
artistes l'art des marionnettes est
alors resté confiné à une petite région
rurale autour de hanoi
ouais
1 1
d'accord
à 70 ans
monsieur hung est bien connue des
corporations de marionnettistes encore
en activité sillonnant sans cesse les
campagnes rendant visite régulièrement
aux marionnettistes
c'est lui qui aide à maintenir en
activité des corporations de plus en
plus fragilisé
à vous de faire le point des agresseurs
l'habitude d'amener la mort et au titre
du thème moi mon manteau et elle n'avait
qu'à y aura la roumanie voit en neymar
fomc pour vous poser
encore là
monsieur young va aider les villageois
dedans nous a ressuscité le numéro du
pêcheur de grenouilles et par la même
occasion il pourra transmettre son
savoir faire sur la manipulation de
cette marionnette assiette et trente
deux jeunes recrues qui devront assurer
la relève au sein de la troupe
monsieur young seront encore souvent
dans le théâtre national de hanoi dont
il a été directeur pendant dix ans
en
qui
malgré son caractère très raffiné et
poétique et malgré les prouesses
techniques qu'ils nécessitent chaque
numéro présenté ici a vu le jour entre
les mains de simples paysans
inspiré par des scènes de leur vie
quotidienne
à
les marionnettistes du théâtre de hanoi
sont des professionnels qui disposent de
moyens importants
les marionnettes sur l'eau sont devenu
une attraction pour les touristes qui
viennent assister de plus en plus
nombreux à ces spectacles et en même
temps paradoxalement dans le berceau qui
les a vu naître c'est à dire les petits
villages très pauvres du delta du fleuve
rouge la survie des marionnettes est
aujourd'hui compromise
oh
o o
la fabrication d'une marionnette se fait
en plusieurs étapes la première d'entre
elles consiste à sculpter la figurine
généralement dans du bois de figuier une
essence abondantes dans les campagnes
c'est un bois qui al'avantage juste
après sa coupe d'être tendre et facile à
sculpter puis de durcir en séchant
autrefois chaque corporation avait en
son sein des artisans spécialisés dans
la sculpture est capable de réaliser des
marionnettes d'un grand raffinement
chacune avec des caractéristiques et des
détails qui lui était propre
actuellement on ne trouve plus guère que
quelques sculpteurs professionnels qui
réalisent des marionnettes pour le
théâtre national de hanoi
mais également pour des petites troupes
comme celle de d'emmener ses artisans
travaillent en combinant les techniques
et le savoir faire de toutes les
corporations
ainsi les connaissances sont partagés ce
qui permet à chaque troupe de bénéficier
de l'expérience des autres
mais du même coup les numéros perdent
progressivement les caractères
distinctifs et des petits détails qui
les identifiait à leur village d'origine
oh
ans
quand
oh
m
non
la deuxième étape de fabrication d'une
marionnette et la peinture et
l'ornementation de la figurine
fraîchement sculpter la marionnette doit
tout d'abord être pons et puis elle est
entièrement recouverte d'un premier
enduit protecteur de couleur noire
l'étanchéité est alors assurée par une
peinture blanche à base d'extraits de
plantes et l'ornementation minutieuse
peut commencer
on fait ressortir certains détails de la
sculpture en les recouvrant de feuilles
d'argent qui lui donneront son aspect
brillant
pour
oui
oh
bon
et
maintenant
en dehors de ses activités artistiques
monsieur on remplit aussi son rôle de
grand-père et lorsque sa fille elle-même
marionnettiste dans la troupe nationale
est en déplacement à l'étranger
son petit-fils s'installe en pension
chez ses grands parents le grand père
conduit alors son petit fils à l'école
monsieur young se destiner à des études
supérieures à hanoi
quand le hasard voulut qu'il passe
devant une affiche annonçant des
auditions pour un groupe de chanteurs
il fut alors sélectionnées parmi un
groupe de sept jeunes gens qui devaient
former la toute première troupe du
théâtre central des marionnettes sur
l'eau du vietnam
à cette époque au chi minh le père de
l'indépendance avait compris
l'importance vitale de mener un autre
combat que celui des armes
il fallait aussi penser à préserver le
patrimoine artistique et culturel du
pays pour les générations futures
je
oh
non
la préparation de la marionnette touche
à sa fin il faut encore recouvrir les
feuilles d'argent d'un enduit
translucide et donner ses couleurs
définitives aux pêcheurs de grenouilles
malgré toutes ces couches protectrices
une marionnette n'est en général qu'une
durée de vie de 3 à 5 ans car elle sera
soumise à l'épreuve de l'eau de la
chaleur et de l'humidité
bagnols
pendant des siècles
l'art des marionnettes sur l'eau est
resté quasiment inconnu en dehors d'une
poignée de villages du nord vietnam où
il été transmis dans les corporations de
paysans marionnettiste les femmes elles
n'étaient pas admises au sein des
troupes car elle risquait pensait-on de
divulguer les secrets de la corporation
suite un éventuel mariage ou à une
histoire d'amour avec un membre d'une
troupe rival
la fatigue et milow celle qui vaut à des
zones à calais
car la carline tout quoi comme
s'opposant voir arriver des jeunes à l
comme aux premiers temps de sa vie
d'artiste monsieur on prend la plume
pour mettre au point le texte du
prochain spectacle
mais à l'époque les conditions étaient
souvent plus difficile qu'aujourd'hui
en effet les maître marionnettiste des
villages refusé de divulguer leurs
connaissances à des personnes
extérieures à leur corporation
qui plus est à des jeunes gens même
auréolé du titre d'artiste national
parfois monsieur young aller rendre
visite à un vieil artiste pendant deux
mois de suite sans qu'ils répondent à la
moindre de ces questions pour qu'enfin
impressionné par la persévérance du
jeune homme il accepte de lui enseigner
son art comme dans ces moments
tourmentés la femme de monsieur young
est toujours à ses côtés pour le
conseiller et le soutenir dans chacun de
ses nouveaux projets
m
barack obama condamné à quatre mois de
la mauritanie à moïse à cette demande
le texte du numéro du pêcheur de
grenouille est inspiré des paroles
originales qui sont consignées dans les
archives sonores de monsieur hung piété
tran les deux jeunes apprentis devront
bien s'en imprégner pour que les
mouvements de la marionnette soit
parfaitement synchrone avec la bande
sonore
malheureusement la corporation de donc
nous ne possède plus d'orchestre
la musique sera donc enregistré sur une
cassette
tu y es tu et ran sont très
consciencieux et prennent leurs
nouvelles responsabilités au sérieux dès
qu'ils ont un moment de libre ils
s'exercent dans la cour de leur maison
pour réussir le numéro il faudra
parvenir à donner l'illusion que la
marionnette bouge tout seul comme par
magie
le public doit se demander si le jeune
pêcheur maladroit va parvenir à attraper
sa grenouille avant l'arrivée du serpent
c'est là tout l'intérêt de la scène ce
numéro est d'autant plus difficile à
réaliser qu'il met en oeuvre deux
marionnettes qui doivent être
parfaitement synchronisé
avec
regard de la loi
non
à
pendant que leurs aînés finissent de
monter le décor du spectacle tu y es tu
et ran vont enfin pouvoir s'entraîner
dans l'eau et ils vont vite se rendre
compte que ce n'est pas aussi simple que
sur la terre ferme
ils devront aussi s'habituer à évoluer
dans une eau qui n'est pas très propre
et qui peut leur sembler froide en ce
mois d'avril dans certaines corporations
on va jusqu'à atteindre l'eau de la mare
avec du caramel pour la rendre opaque et
mieux cacher les mécanismes aux yeux des
spectateurs les adam nous la boue en
suspension dans la main fera la faire
cantines hallal de sa vie
dernière étape de leur apprentissage
tu y es tu et ran prennent place
derrière le vidéo de bambou à l'endroit
même où demain devant plusieurs
centaines de spectateurs
ils devront exécuter leurs numéros sans
le moindre faux mouvement
je
en ce début d'année lunaire tous les
villages sont en fait c'est un moment
très important dans les campagnes pour
monsieur hung et sa femme
ce sera l'occasion de rendre visite à
leur famille mais aussi d'oublier
pendant quelques heures les préparatifs
du spectacle de dons monsieur on en
profite pour retrouver ses vieux amis
participer à la cérémonie en l'honneur
des ancêtres et partager un repas
familial
monsieur holmes est issu d'une famille
qui possédait beaucoup de rizières dans
le village de dông by sa mère et est
éleveuse de vers à soie et tisseuse et
son père avaient été élus meilleurs
laboureurs du village l'école primaire
où il allait avec ses deux frères se
trouvait à une trentaine de kilomètres
de leur maison au début des années 50 le
village fut entièrement incendié par les
français et ses habitants dur se replier
dans le centre du pays
ce n'est qu'en 1954 après l'indépendance
que monsieur young et sa famille pu
retrouver le chemin de leur terre natale
total
avant le spectacle les marionnettistes
partagent un repas offert par les
villageois
ce sera leur seule rétribution
il
le temps est à la plaisanterie mais les
artistes sont impatients de retrouver
leurs marionnettes pour commencer le
spectacle
oh
on installe des sièges pour les
dignitaires les paysans se presse de
rentrée des champs pour être aux
premières loges
l'excitation monte en murmure qu après
20 ans d'absence le numéro du pêcheur de
grenouilles fera à nouveau son
apparition pendant le spectacle et sera
exécuté par deux jeunes marionnettistes
oh
en attendant le spectacle monsieur um
pense à ces deux élèves comme lui à ses
débuts il les imagine plaint d'un
mélange de fierté d'appréhension et il
sait que les villageois observeront
leurs numéros avec une attention
bienveillante
dans le
on
non
oh
la barre
sans lui je ne voulais pas flatteur mais
la mémoire
non
mais bon
il y a
on
là
ah ah
le numéro du pêcheur de grenouilles se
termine sous les acclamations du public
dès demain
cette scène éphémère sera démontée et
marionnettes seront rangés tandis que tu
y es tu te ramener les autres artistes
redeviendront de simples paysans et
retourneront à leurs rizières
il restera aux villageois le souvenir
d'un spectacle haut en couleur et celui
du numéro du pêcheur de grenouilles à
qui la troupe a redonné vie après 20 ans
d'absence et il restera monsieur young
la joie d'avoir transmis son savoir à
ces jeunes gens nouveaux dépositaires
d'un art qui continuera encore longtemps
a rythmé les saisons du delta du fleuve
rouge
on
non
oh
o o